public sénat avec le soutien de mutualia
la mutuelle des territoires vous
présente c'est vous la france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des chevaux des cochons des ânes des
poules à perte de vue entre les 15
kilomètres d'allées de cette foire
nous sommes le troisième week-end de
septembre à une trentaine de kilomètres
de grenoble
et pour la 7 100 99e année consécutive
le village de beaucroissant et les
théâtres de la plus grande foire aux
bestiaux de france huit siècles de vente
d'animaux sans interruption
beaucroissant est évidemment la plus
ancienne foire de france avec parfois
des démonstrations de compétences
surprenante
attention sur deux prestations
[Musique]
des hypnotiseurs de lapins des vendeurs
de chaussettes une fête foraine et des
restaurants plus de 30 hectares de
commerçants dédié traditionnellement aux
animaux et à l'agriculture
près de 2000 entrepreneurs du secteur
agricole vient exposer ici des bêtes des
produits fermiers ou du matériel et
chaque année ce sont des centaines de
milliers de visiteurs qui viennent
déguster des spécialités culinaires de
toute la france acquérir leur prochain
compagnons domestiques évolué ou
profiter d'une des grandes fêtes de la
région
[Musique]
le vendredi matin dans un coin de la
foire a lieu la vente des bovins des
vaches charolaises des taureaux et
quelques vaches d'hérens une race qui
avait failli disparaître du cheptel
français mais que cet éleveur max
josserand a contribué à sauver
on est en et si on les a
au milieu entre les producteurs mc c'est
d'ailleurs une figure de la foire depuis
quelques années les bovins ont perdu
leur place de star de beaucroissant max
est le dernier à vendre ses bêtes à
l'ancienne en les exposant directement
dans les allées ce matin gérard
justement venu acheter un reproducteur
pour son élevage et max u est mis de
côté à manille met de choix
tu sais que j'aurai déjà vendu le
taureau trop fort si je n'avais pas
attendu boîte est gentil l'aurait bas
c'est normal bas pour le moment on va
regarder le taureau ci lui plaît ah ça
c'est déjà la première des choses
voilà et on discute du sérieux voilà
après on verra l'argent à au plat au
c'est bon bon
alors deux choses quand même bon il a
deux ans et demi et a vu offrir ensemble
voilà je t'ai dis qu'il ya le rap ou 10
ans et en plus il a la corde fille
nature vue ouais et puis il est sympa
quoi revoilà le prix du taureau n'est
pas vraiment ouvert à la négociation
en fait les deux éleveurs savent plus ou
moins en avance la valeur de l'animal
via une base on a un prix de viande à
peu près de carcasse mais après pour la
reproduction c'est que ça ou un peu plus
voilà donc le prise d'effets liés à peu
près comme ça je le vendrais 2050 euros
je pense que c'est pas pas du mauvais
travail et bien voilà chez toi danton
cheptel ça devrait faire impeccable
gérard n'a pas discuté le prix de son
taureau il faut dire qu'en dehors
d'événements festifs et traditionnels
comme cette foire une vache français est
en crise depuis plusieurs années le
métier d'éleveur connaît une profonde
mutation
[Musique]
nous sommes quelques jours avant le
début de la foire
il est 4h30 du matin d'exploitation de
max josserand se trouve dans le village
de saint cassien à quelques kilomètres
seulement de beaucroissant pour être
éleveur il faut savoir se lever tôt par
an de produits ce matin max part de sa
ferme avec un camion vide
il va faire le tour des élevages de la
région car max josserand n'est pas
seulement éleveurs il est également
marchand de bestiaux
c'est à dire qu'il va directement chez
les fermiers chercher le bétail qu'il va
ensuite revendre aux abattoirs alors que
tu t'en vas aller à village
mais là je dépasse 12 h et un éleveur à
un jeune éleveur qui viennent
s'installer là ça à faire à peu près un
an
alors allé chercher deux taurillons
enchaîné depuis que max est installé il
ya cinquante ans le métier a bien changé
des fermes dit-on biassais les fermes
qui ont vraiment un bon gestionnaire et
à beaune administratif
voilà c'est contraire à à la valeur de
gaulle à les agriculteurs doivent en
effet devenir des experts en
administration pour soutenir l'élevage
l'état l'union européenne ont mis en
place un maquis des aides financières
primes spéciales aux bovins mâles aident
aux bovins allaitants dotation jeune
agriculteur remboursement des taxes sur
le carburant
une complexité souvent incompatibles
avec le travail quotidien des
agriculteurs
ça va en prouvant berbère toujours
optimiste et si un tournage lui est pas
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire si on
peut pas compter sur toi on est foutu
bon bah
quentin seulement 23 ans et il est tout
seul pour s'occuper de son troupeau avec
l'aide de max et va devoir identifier
dans cet enclos et de taurillons qu'il
veut vendre je ne mens pas les numéros y
en a qui hélas oui îlots je prends bien
là
le sol quoi tu es là
fauchage c'est bon on attaque une fois
les taurillons dans le camion
il va falloir remplir un peu de
paperasse et vérifier les papiers
d'identité des animaux une procédure
indispensable pour garantir la
traçabilité d'autres 32 61
le gros souci c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya
on a très très peu de marges donc en
viande donc
le problème c'est quand on vend une bête
on la vend pas à perte nous n'avons pas
assez cher par rapport à ce qu'on doit
et va donc c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
je suis un petit atelier de vente
directe du coup je propose aux clients
des coleaders ce qui permet de valoriser
un peu les bêtes qui sont 10 à supprimer
les intermédiaires et la bête et la bête
elle me revient au pays que j'adore
normalement je le vois l'avant quand on
est un tout jeune éleveur et s'est
installé en janvier un jeune homme
courageux qui réinvente une agriculture
à taille humaine en surface j'ai pas
besoin de plus en nombre de bêtes il
faut que j'arrive à elle en a assez pour
cela j'en ai assez pour être tout seul
tu as comme une bête maintenant un peu
près de là et je suis à 138 bête
actuellement et d'augmenter l'âge
saillantes bas 48 cette année donc il
faut que j'arrive à 50 vêlage et puis
après on arrête d'augmenter parce que
après photo photo la firme de loi c
voilà bon on y va on embraye parce que
aller
ben ouais
m
la main
ces dernières années les fermes se
raréfient un phénomène qui change peu à
peu la physionomie des territoires
des exploitations sont de plus en plus
éloignées les unes des gens ça veut dire
que le tissu rural est plus aussi garni
qu'il était par le passé
salut mec c'est bientôt fini sa tournée
il doit faire un dernier arrêt à saint
michel de saint geoirs l'occasion de
saluer tous les artisans de la filière
bonjour way sortira peut nous dire
bonjour ça va le fromage est là c'est
bien aller il est là 11 hockey
dernière ferme de la tournée max vient
chercher une vaches et un veau chez
xavier mabille surnommé zaz xavier l'a
bien compris le métier d'éleveur et très
contraignant et peu rémunérateur alors
il diversifie ses activités et cultive
des noirs un produit bien plus rentable
et moins difficile à travailler
oui la permanence et la nôtre nous fait
tenir ce que du lait qui s'est pas tué
par un buteur celui à 10 heures pendant
malade ça va bien il faut dire que
depuis quelques années les cours
mondiaux de la viande se sont effondrés
et les éleveurs de la région sont
évidemment directement impactés
aujourd'hui on a un bon vaut à 200 250
euros c'est dieu moi je me rappelle il
ya trente ans on achetait des veaux 2000
francs ça fait 300 euros va-t'en plus de
vingt ans pour tenter de rester
compétitif vous aviez a fait le choix
d'un élevage très moderne son étable n'a
rien à voir avec une ferme
traditionnelle vous allez le voir
vous aviez est un producteur de lait il
très moderne et les vaches ne vont pas
s'en plaindre
les bêtes sont couchés sur des tapis
doit s'étendre même une jambe la pousse
des tendres
voilà donc de belles passes tressées
bonne d'être énervé ria le plus étonnant
c'est cette grosse machine avec un écran
bleu il s'agit d'un robot de traite une
sorte de fermiers du 21e siècle il n'ya
plus d'interventions humaines
le robot se charge tout seul de trouver
le pis de cette laitières et l'hygiène
est parfaite
m vous aviez n'a rien à faire les bêtes
viennent d'elles-mêmes dans la machine
quand leur fille devienne trop lourd n'a
pour seule vache qui va venir la voilà m
impeccable la porte se ferme
automatiquement
cette machine représente un
investissement très conséquents pour
xavier entre les bâtiments adaptés et le
robot l'éleveur s'est endettée de plus
de 700000 euros
mais la machine permet de piloter très
finement la production de la ferme et
xavier supervise les vaches directement
derrière son écran
le métier de fermier a bien changé
regarde il est dans un fauteuil de pdg
mais ordi
et katiana sydor ça tapait le téléphone
l'ordinateur peut appeler directement le
fermier sur son portable et décide aussi
qu'elle vache doit partir à l'abattoir
donc c'est un rouge des barbares
d'abord en jaune c'est tout cela et warp
adams et lalanne ont décoché la lah deux
pays n'ont pas été très et abel est
incomplète de 3 pi n'a pas été fait
correctement
celle-là c'est là dans les prochaines
qui vendent dans le tenir un match
vous aviez presque est devenu ingénieur
mais tous les éleveurs ne sont pas en
mesure d'investir dans ce genre de ferme
ultra moderne
[Musique]
mexes et fini sa tournée et lui reste
maintenant à décharger les bêtes dans
son étable et là les saveurs
traditionnelles restent indispensables
[Musique]
on se faire une échelle improvisé et
surtout on va y donner un petit coup de
voix parce que la voix de plus que le
bâton allez on allait aller
[Musique]
le reste de la journée de max est
réservé au travail et de ministres hâtif
et pour ça il s'est fait aider par
christelle sa fille
max est encore un fermier traditionnel
lui n'a pas de robot mais pour l'aider
il a une famille dans l'agriculture
depuis des siècles il n'y a pas eu
besoin des mouvements féministes pour
comprendre l'importance du rôle des
femmes
moi personnellement ainsi j'avais pas eu
mari à mes côtés je n'aurais jamais pu
faire ce que ce que j'ai fait quoi que
ce soit mari ou creissels si je suis pas
là elles sont capables d'acheter à ou
d'acheter nos achats de la connaître
aussi bien que moi et destiné aussi bien
que moi
le métier d'éleveur connaît une crise
mondiale qui rend le travail des
fermiers peu rentable pris entre
l'industrie agroalimentaire et la grande
distribution
les paysans n'ont plus le choix il faut
se moderniser
pourtant les contraintes de cette
activité sont nombreuses et c'est aussi
en respectant les traditions que les
agriculteurs peuvent trouver un soutien
la foire de beaucroissant s'inscrit
justement parmi ces traditions qui
depuis des siècles soutiennent toute la
filière de l'élevage
nous sommes jeudi matin pour l'instant
le petit village de beaucroissant est
encore bien calme mais dans quelques
heures ce sont des hordes d'animaux et
de visiteurs qui vont investir les rues
du pont y accueillir la plus grande
foire de france a évidemment des
conséquences sur la vie de la commune le
cours normal de l'existant s'arrête
brusquement ce qui n'est pas pour
déplaire aux élèves de l'école demain
ils ont droit à un jour de vacances rien
que pour eux en général on s'organise
avec les mamies pour les garder
ou les papiers et puis voilà
pour les parents c'est un peu plus
compliqué ils vont se retrouver coincés
dans nos villages j'ai un métier où je
suis obligé d'utiliser mon véhicule
pauvres pour me déplacer toute la
journée donc il est plus pratique pour
moi de poser un jour de congé et puis de
profiter de la foire du coup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
retour dans la ferme de max josserand et
les 4 heures du matin et c'est le grand
jour dans quelques heures
max d'un vendra ses dettes dans les
allées de la foire il doit rassembler
les vaches qu'il va présenter aux
acheteurs une activité matinale qui
requiert une certaine expérience font
manipuler avec délicatesse surtout
réfléchir ne pas se faire agresser par
une vache c'est la grande loge qu'on a
vue là c'est là qu'on n'est pas trop sa
région je deviens nous
il ya nous attaquerons porter atteinte à
notre produit
[Musique]
max prépare plusieurs camions la petite
berline cette vache sombre et mise à
l'écart de ses congénères plus
volumineuse il faut dire que marine est
une survivance c'est une vache d'hérens
une race venus de suisse
autrefois très répandu dans les alpes
mais les reims beaucoup moins rentable
que leurs cousines charolaise ont bien
failli disparaître
c'est les vaches vont alors découvrir
dans votre département
en quelques décennies les amoureux de la
vache d'hérens comme max on sauver
l'espèce en france aujourd'hui elle
serait autour de 500 l'éleveur va tenter
de les faire connaître l'occasion de la
foire
le convoi est prêt direction
beaucroissant
max fait ce trajet depuis 68 ans bonjour
mais moi ça va on est réveillé ce matin
à tout à l'heure
si max est devenu une figure de mots
croissant c'est qu'il est le dernier
vendeurs traditionnels de la foire qui
expose ses bêtes directement dans les
travées une occasion pour lui de
soutenir toutes les filières bovines
ça crée un peu un mouvement voilà et
puis on remonte site où tous les anciens
copains les anciennes pompes et de tous
les anciens agriculteurs avec qui on a
travaillé qui viennent nous dire bonjour
c'est toujours un moment très très
sympathique fois
[Musique]
le soleil se lève et à quelques mètres
du stand de max dans la mairie se trouve
le petit studio de la station de radio
de la foire et c'est une tradition
c'est à ce micro que s'ouvre l'événement
bienvenue dans la seine 199e
beaucroissant c'est parti pour trois
jours de foire elles sont la radio de la
fois rencontre les bulls 9 heures dans
les allées les visiteurs se ruent sur
les stands pendant un week end le petit
village de 1500 arbres sa population
multipliée par quatre centres pendant la
foire vont croissant accueillerait plus
de six cent mille visiteurs
la mairie du village deviendra quartier
général louis zabel de l'est la
régisseuse règle tous les petits détails
l'un des exposants n'est par exemple pas
satisfait d'un emplacement qu'il occupe
en 2016 effectivement il avait un numéro
plus par là j'ai pas sorti le plan mais
en
il était bien pensants et en fait je
veux travailler sur les épaules
d'isabelle repose la bonne marche de la
plus grande foire de france et c'est sa
première foire au poste de régisseuse
ses aveux dans l'angle qui avait proposé
de mettre votre voiture l'ag on va aller
voir sur le terrain c'est juste la salue
colette pardon juge dira bonjour ça va
et toi ça va
il va avoir un camion juste avoir une
voiture là ça vous dérange pas beau pas
super alors je reviens je vais demander
qui sont venus regarder s'il y avait des
désistements si la personne n'était pas
et palau de à la deuxième annonce à la
radio lui peut il va pouvoir travailler
là en face c'est un baptême du feu ça
heureusement qu'à toute l'équipe de la
mairie qui sait bien ce qu'il ya à faire
parce que c'est quand même
impressionnant ouais c'est pas mais ça
se passe bien servi de foire bonjour
isabelle est à la tête d'une tour de
contrôle qui va s'agiter pendant trois
jours
je vais écouter il est bientôt trois
heures e
ça s'est calmé quand même
après tout se passe d'y renoncer pas
encore arrêté on n'est pas allés
déjeuner
mais tout se passe bien dans les travées
des allées nous recrutons mérine la
petite vache d'hérens mais elle a changé
de propriétaire florian est venue d'aix
en provence il est découvert merlyn par
hasard et il en est tombé amoureux
c'est la première fois en cause unique
j'étais venu dans l'optique d'acheter
des chauvauds et au final on repart avec
une vache qu'on n'a pas trouvé de four
c'est pour faire de l'élevage le pari de
max josserand et gagner la vache
d'hérens va se répandre de nouveau sur
le territoire le premier soir toute la
foire est en fête
les éleveurs font place aux vrais neige
de forains vont croissant est un
événement majeur de la rentrée
touristique de la région
[Musique]
les lendemains l'immense tente du
restaurant ne désemplit pas toute la
journée les visiteurs font la queue pour
déguster le plat traditionnel de la
foire la viande de boeuf avec des frites
un plat qui se classe toujours dans le
peloton de tête des mets préférés des
français
une image bien éloignée de la crise qui
touche les éleveurs bovins à
beaucroissant la foire est un gage de
tradition et de qualité et c'est l'une
des pistes pour garantir l'avenir des
agriculteurs français beaucroissant
permet de valoriser le cheptel des
éleveurs avec le grand événement du week
end le concours de charolaises la
charolaise c'est la star des vaches la
plus consommée dans le monde alors des
éleveurs de toute la région sont venus
pour tenter de décrocher un prix au
concours
alexis le venant est un de ces éleveurs
qui rêvent de décrocher un prix à tout
juste 17 ans le jeune homme est en
première dans un lycée agricole
il travaille avec son père sur
l'exploitation familiale alors pour le
concours
il se transforme en coiffeur pour vaches
alors je mets du stick pour cette comme
du gel pour les hommes pour repousser
les poils remonter les poils pourrait
faire friser pour donner du volume mais
avant ce travail de finition
il y a des mois d'efforts pour présenter
des bêtes parfaite en les dres trois
mois al avance allait intégrer ces gens
sont las vegas party dont elle a
l'habitude de sortir un bon coup
maintenant et même les cornes de vache
son briquet par les éleveurs c'est
toujours un petit plus pour que sont un
des plus jolis que sept ou huit femmes
quatre mâts qui s'est pareillement un
type 3
plus jolie et plus harmonieuse pour
alexis la foire de beaucroissant c'est
l'événement de l'année
un rendez-vous qui rythment la vie des
éleveurs de la région depuis que mon
père mais des vaches et veaux croissant
j'ai toujours suivi
c'est c'est convivial on arrive c'est
nos vacances on va dire ces trois jours
ces trois jours de vacances pour ces
jeunes hommes des 17 ans s'est lancé
dans un secteur en crise n'a rien de
facile
alors une seule solution travail et la
qualité de la viande à un petit peu
remontée alors diminuer la ley elle a
remonté un petit peu on est là on siens
on essaye après j'espère dans l'avenir
que ça évoluera avec de mieux
mais en mieux mais j'ai une passion je
vais faire ma passion après on verra
bien
[Musique]
le concours commence alexis va présenter
sa vache un jury qui notera tous les
détails
l'aspect la morphologie le poids mais
aussi le comportement des bêtes
alexis va présenter plusieurs bêtes de
son cheptel et les faire défiler dans
cet enclos sous l'oeil inquisiteur du
jury derrière lui raphaël son père soit
jusqu'au dernier moment les animaux qui
vont défiler un père heureux de passer
le virus de l'agriculture un seul fils
et en suisse comment j'ai appris et
maintenant on est un duo et la porte a
saisi les saisines et sa formation
peut-être que moi j'aurais pu
améliorer le cheptel la quantité de la
qualité continue à travailler ce que
manger j'ai créé en fait les juges
doivent maintenant noté les charolaises
des lauves et nous c'est le grand moment
pour le ter et les fils le verdict tombe
alexis et raphaël ont gagné le premier
prix la consécration
g et c'est après le résultat que les
vaches se rebellent un premier prix
d'ensemble
la petite famille est récompensé pour la
cohérence de son cheptel les vaches
correspondent tout des critères très
spécifiques
un troupeau particulièrement harmonieux
alexis a du mal à trouver ses mots non
plaisir on est content
j'ai parlé de 10
son ultra nerveux et provoque lycées
grâce à ce prix raphaël et alexis ont pu
valoriser leur travail
non seulement le jury les a récompensés
mais en plus le prix de leurs animaux
reproducteurs va augmenter la guerre
entier d'un revenu plus en accord avec
leurs efforts
[Musique]
nous sommes dimanche soir déjà les
premiers exposants rangent leurs stands
du côté de chez max josserand c'est
l'heure du bilan de la vente des vaches
potes sont deux mais presque voilà ton
marester 4,4 sur un bon c'est toujours
toujours bon croissant on emporte
vraiment une bonne équipe ça ça se passe
bien
3la dans la joie la bonne humeur depuis
huit siècles les agriculteurs de france
viennent présenter et vendre leurs plus
beaux animaux a beau croissant au regard
de cette tradition la crise que connaît
l'élevage français pourrait sembler
passagère pourtant la filière connaît
des difficultés inédites concurrence
internationale
changement des mentalités et des modes
de consommation
l'agriculture fait face à des défis
nouveaux
mais grâce à son événement unique
beaucroissant peut répondre à certaines
de ces questions
c'est en favorisant la qualité que
l'élevage français pourra survivre en
comptant sur la passion des hommes et
des femmes qui ont consacré leur vie à
ce métier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
public sénat avec le soutien de mutualia
la mutuelle des territoires vous a
présenté c'est vous la france